le poulet se fabriquent aujourd'hui à
peu près comme une boîte de détergents
fin des années 60 la france découvre
l'élevage intensif à la télévision une
pratique industrielle
apparu à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale où l'animal devient une machine
de production
on les appelle d'ailleurs des veaux en
batterie que l'on élève en trois mois
avec les régimes et artificielle qui
leur permettent de devenir rapidement
des veaux de boucherie volailles élevées
en batterie porcs et bovins entassés et
engraissés sur de petites surfaces
face à cette réalité certains
journalistes s'interroge je risque pour
le consommateur ce que cette
industrialisation de la distribution de
la production elle je crois qu'au
contraire d'un risque le consommateur il
ya déjà trouvé de très gros avantage à
cette époque quelques voix s'élèvent
aussi contre la pollution issue de ces
élevages intensifs en 1972 par exemple
dans un village normand une porcherie
industrielle mettait en colère des
habitants
le mauvais traitement des déjections de
porc polluer l'eau de la rivière et en
quoi vous gêne-t-elle cette pollution
monsieur py le gène du fait désirer
installés ici plusieurs mois que 7 ou 8
bat pour rêver détruites
maintenant c'est impossible du fait que
le plomb est pollué depuis un peuple et
500 m par l'existence d'une porcherie
industrielle aujourd'hui encore
l'organisation des nations unies pour
l'alimentation et l'agriculture affirme
que l'élevage intensif est l'une des
causes principales des problèmes
environnementaux retour dans les années
70 face aux dérives de certains élevages
industriels
les premières réglementations
européennes sont adoptées dès 1976
principalement sur les conditions de
détention des animaux de production
le président valéry giscard d'estaing
prenait aussi la parole notamment des
pratiques qui ne sont pas je dirais
admissible pour ce qui est de certains
certaines techniques d'abattage des
animaux
nous avons pris les textes mais je vous
indique que je compte en faire vérifier
prochainement et dans le détail
l'application la législation continuera
ensuite de se renforcer mais l'élevage
industriel fait toujours des marques en
1982 dans son livre le médecin jean
claude louette parlait même d'un grand
massacre l'animal n'est plus considérée
que comme une chose c'est une machine à
pondre ou une machine à faire de la
viande est finalement une machine à
crever l'élevage intensif fait encore
aujourd'hui partie des pratiques
agricoles régulièrement dénoncé par
l'association l214 notamment selon elle
en france 80% des animaux sont encore
confiné dans des élevages intensifs
[Musique]